it's the first of the month you know
what that means rents due
what's up guys I'm tired Matthew also
known as the landlord they called me the
landlord cuz I own the field and I take
care of chief Kingman right now my
social responsibility goes much beyond
that
a lot of people have been impacted by
Cobra at 19 especially in my hometown of
New Orleans I'm hoping to find a few
families that I could really impact and
help and love and support I'm looking
forward to checking them out I know you
love me and I wanted to share with you a
family that could use you Courtney is
extremely talented artist and a mother
of twins with autism a children for
lyric and Julius Courtney is not a
survivor
pulling up team Courtney was diagnosed a
few weeks back and I honestly remember
her telling me the hardest part of
fighting the virus was not being able to
touch her children she just hopped her
son julius for the first time about a
week ago and he was excited and so is
she
thank you again Tommy this would mean
the world to lurk in their family hey
how you doing hey how you doing how's
everybody doing
it's so good to see you guys smiling
yeah he's friendly yeah I'm from New
Orleans so I mean how is everything been
because I mean I've heard that you
tested positive for cookironi virus how
did that go for you were you able to
work well I actually have been able to
work since before I was tested positive
because of them being home from school
and then my cousin got sick and she also
lives with us unfortunately she was
hospitalized but I wasn't I probably may
have needed to be but I couldn't leave
my kids at home so we both fully
recovered we still have the
after-effects sometimes I feel like I
need like a breathing treatment from my
asthma pump but that was in like March I
didn't get to hug them until late April
early made so you can you imagine living
in the same house with your kids and not
having any kind of physical contact I
want actually a good question if she's
if she's listening how was it how was it
for you when your mom was sick and she
wasn't able to hug you how did that go
for you except I wasn't my mom I hugged
my brother at last I want to get
personal with you for a second I want to
ask you because I I mean I've heard I've
heard it you you told me you haven't
been able to work yeah
you've been self quarantine how has it
been financially for you I was without a
car for ten years and on march 13th the
day before everything started shutting
down and every I bought a car so now I
have a car note I have this car
insurance that's higher than my car note
behind on water bill behind on the light
bill and just trying to keep food in the
house man these two teenagers can eat
you out of house at home you know my
nickname is the landlord and I'm I'm the
person that runs the field so I control
everything and then also I take care of
the kingdom so I'm always thinking about
my community and and people of need and
I usually shared it with me I mean and
I'm so grateful that that I'll be able
to talk to you and I feel like you
deserve so much more really everything
you think you've been able to overcome I
want to be able to help you I want to
show you some love so right now I want
you to check your text for me please so
I sent you one month's rent and that my
friends at Zell they were able to donate
the next month's rent so you're actually
going to be covered for the next two
months you know I love my community and
so anytime I'm able to hear stories like
this I always want to be a part of those
people lives and because it always helps
change mine
so it was good talking to you today it
was good seeing you guys
and I wish you guys the best going
forward I wish you guys much much help
to you and thank you thank you so much
for looking out you know not everybody's
out there looking out for little people
you know thank you so much for looking
out for me and in these two loans I got
right here they thank 50 but they go yes
they always be a baby
America